Investigators on the Gilgo Beach
serial murder case
were just seen taking boxes
of what appeared to be evidence
from the suspect's New York home.
Earlier, investigators
searched his yard using a K-9 and ground
penetrating radar.
Authorities are also looking
to his properties
in South Carolina, Nevada.
A human is charged with murder
in the deaths of three of the go
go for the 59 year old architects
also the prime suspect
in the disappearance
and killing of the fourth woman.
But he hasn't been charged yet
in that case.
Now the go go for a group of women
whose remains were found near
Long Island
Gilgo beach in 2010
few women had been pleaded
or excuse me
has pleaded not guilty
in three of those murders early.
Earlier
I spoke with a makeup artist
in her hair and makeup
artist named Nikki Brass.
She said she went on a date
with a suspect in the summer of 2015
How did you
first encounter
the man you believed to be the girl?
Go kill her.
I, I don't believe it to be him
for a while.
And you're convinced this is.
I am Calvin and I am 1,000% sure.
So this guy reaches out to you.
Did he say immediately
he wanted you to come to his house? Yes.
But the issue was
he lives in Nassau County
and he was in Massapequa.
And I'm not familiar
with the area, and I'm very locational
and I needed GPS to go home,
and I could live there for five years.
I'm bad.
So.
And I didn't have friends nearby
in case anything happened.
So I asked them
if you would meet me in your address,
the steam room.
Because in poor Jeff, it's a small town.
It's a restaurant.
Yeah. Okay.
It's a small town. I knew the area.
I had friends locally
and people nearby
that if something were to go wrong
and they could be there quickly.
So you do meet with him at the restaurant
in Fort Jefferson?
Yeah.
Well, before I met him,
I was at Sharkey Cheese with my sister,
and I had said to her,
I showed her picture,
and I said, Hey,
this is who I'm going out with tonight.
If anything happens
is what he looks like.
So and I would do that.
I would do that
for every time I did it just
for my own safety.
I think I jumped ahead.
So he reached out to you.
You asked him for a picture? Yeah.
Because I said I wanted to know
who I was looking for.
I didn't want to show up at a restaurant
and be like, who who's meeting me here?
You know what I mean?
So.
And you showed the picture to your sister
and gave her the picture
I didn't give it to her.
I showed it to her on my phone.
And I said,
this is who I'm going to be with.
So, you know, this looks like
and who it is
at the time
we used fake names
so you can give her a name.
And then we met.
We didn't meet in front of his car
or where I could have gone
to play it or a description of it.
We met directly
in front of the restaurant.
What did you think
when you first saw him?
Oh, my God, he's massive.
At the time, I was,
you know, 24 years old.
I was like 120 £130.
And, you know, I hadn't had kids yet.
And he was a gigantic man.
Like, I had to look up at him. Gigantic.
And it wasn't just his height,
it was his weight.
It was everything. He was just this huge,
very like
overbearing type of weight, I guess.
Almost carried his weight to intimidate.
And what was he like
when you were sitting
across the table from him?
So before we sat down, he shook my hand.
Was it sad to say
there is
no reason to have a handshake firm
He had a he had a really strong hand.
Yeah.
Like, I get
I get that firm
handshake to show confidence to
you know what I mean?
But his is like like a dress like like
like an aggressive grip,
you know what I mean?
Other than that, he seemed normal.
He seemed like he told me.
Well, first of all, right.
When we sat down, I said, hi.
It's nice to meet you.
My real name is Nicky.
And he just said, Rex.
He didn't
give me a last name or anything.
We sat down.
He seemed perfectly normal at first.
He seemed like
your typical guy
who was bored with his life, you know,
and wanted to kind of excitement,
you know what I mean?
It didn't get weird
until he asked me
if I was a true crime fan
when he asked you
if you were a true crime fan.
Yes, if I was a true crime fan.
And I am like, I am.
I'm a serial killer buff.
I won't even lie.
I it was when he said, well,
do you know about the Gilgo Beach,
the Gilgo beach murders?
He actually brought it up. Yeah.
He said he has said to me, exactly,
do you know about the Gilgo
beach runners?
And I was like,
yeah, I'm from Long Island.
Everybody from Long Island
knows about them, you know what I mean?
And that's
when he started talking about it.
But here's the thing.
When he brought it up,
his whole demeanor changed.
And he he sat up straighter.
You know,
he had like a smirk on his face.
He seemed almost like
too excited to talk about it.
And then once he did
start talking about it,
it didn't seem like a true crime.
Fan who just knows information
that I've seen on TV or read.
It seemed like somebody
who is reliving it.
One the one thing I remember
specifically was he said to me,
how do you think
they get rid of the bodies
without going notice?
And I said, I have no clue.
I've never been to Gilgo beach
I don't know the access points.
Like I couldn't tell you
anything about it. I have no idea.
And he said,
what if they'd shredded
through the marsh though,
with the burlap sacks,
you would never see them.
And he's like, it's a
very dark and desolate area.
What happened that day you
decide at some point
this is not a good idea.
So after he started talking
about everything,
he ended it with saying, Oh,
I live by Global Lead.
First of all, I am kidding me.
I'm not after telling me all of this.
You then tell him you live
and you're going to reach him.
It's dark and desolate.
So that weird to me. I don't know.
And that's where he wanted
you to go to his house? Yeah.
Near Gilgo Beach.
Yeah. One.
I wouldn't go with him.
That's when he started seeming
visually very agitated,
almost like I put in all this work.
I came all the way out to Suffolk.
I took you to dinner.
I met your lovely wife.
Are you not going back with me? Like.
Like almost like I owed it to him.
And that's why I'm like it.
He even though he seemed agitated and he.
He used as, like, weight and size
to almost try to intimidate me even more.
Thank goodness you. You didn't.
I was terrified.
I called somebody
and meet me in the parking lot
to make sure I got to my car. Okay.
When you saw the newsbreak
and you saw his picture,
I immediately texted my little sister
and told her to go look at the news,
and I said I was right.
I knew it
because after that dinner for years,
I'm telling you, years, I told everybody.
I'm telling you I went to dinner
with the Gilgo beach killer.
I know it's him.
I want to dinner with him.
And I mean, when he got arrested,
my sister recognized him.
But not only that, it's hard
to forget
somebody who's like six foot six, £300,
who's an architect in Manhattan
and lives in Massapequa.
You know, those are very specific details
so when you saw his image,
though, once the news broke,
you were like 1,000%.
That is the guy.
I am so sure
I could sit across from him today.
And I'd be like, I know you remember me.
And if you try saying you don't
I you're lying.
Like, I know he knows who I am
and this is one,
but you you've changed
your life has changed a lot since then.
Yeah.
And that's that's
why I came out, the one I'm making.
I don't wanna drag my whole history
through the mud
where everybody knows I'm a former escort
or I suffered from addiction
or this and that.
I want people to realize that I am a mom
and a hairstylist and a makeup artist.
And I was able to change my life,
and these girls were.
And they didn't get the opportunity
to get out of that situation.
And most people in that situation
are vulnerable and desperate
and have no other
means or outlet or ways to go.
And that's one reason
perhaps he was targeting.
Yeah. You.
I think he targeted women
that were less likely to go to.
Yes.
And that was another reason
they're going forward
because I feel like
there's women out there
who probably had a lot more
of a dangerous encounter
with him than I did
and got away
who were too scared to talk about it.
Nikki, I wish you the best.
Thank you so much for talking.
You're welcome. Thank you for having.